il y à 70 ans très précisément le 10
janvier 1929 une silhouette de reporter
naissait dans un album dessiné s'était
teint teint créé par hergé le premier
album s'appelait donc tintin chez les
soviets le ton était nettement
anticommuniste soixante dix ans après
les éditions casterman réédite cet album
à l'origine d'une longue série de 200
millions d'exemplaires de toutes les
aventures de tintin vendus dans le monde
commentaire pierre emmanuel luneau avec
jacques girard vous avez bien entendu
vingt mille cinq cents francs pour cet
album de tintin et milou
mais attention il ne s'agit pas de
n'importe quel album tintin au pays des
soviets et le tout premier les aventures
du reporter à la houppette la valeur de
cet ouvrage qui vient d'être réédité
chez casterman est à rechercher ailleurs
au siège de l'éditeur en belgique un
homme recueille depuis plus de trente
ans toutes les parutions d'hergé c'est
dans le petit vingtième que le 10
janvier 29 paraît la première planche de
tintin tintin au pays des soviets
l'album qui reprend l'ensemble de cette
parution soir en 1930 et en 30 et 31
la parution des soviets se fait dans
coeurs vaillants c'est à dire dans la
presse pour les jeunes français après
cette date on n'entendra plus parler de
cet album pourtant il regorge déjà de
trouvailles graphiques très efficace les
voitures par exemple ils sont déformés
par la vitesse
certains gags eux aussi seront repris
des dizaines d'années plus tard
tintin qui est sur une pente neigeuse
qui forme une boule de neige et qui est
arrêté par un tronc d'arbre
on va retrouver la scène avec le
capitaine haddock dans le temple du
soleil et c'est ça qui sauvera
d'ailleurs le capitaine parce que
d'autres méchants qui la même aventure
arrivons tomber la libye
en 1929 hergé travail pour des
publications catholiques conservatrices
comme le boy scouts belges ou le petit
vingtième le rédacteur en chef l'abbé
wallez je pose alors la lecture d'un
pamphlet anti communiste dont il doit
s'inspirer longtemps hergé restera gênés
par ce titre il ne renie pas en tant que
premier album mais il l'a renié tout un
temps en temps que que vraiment dignes
d'être publiées
et puis après quand il en redemande la
publication c'est parce que ça devient
des archives historiques
ça devient un témoignage c'est ce que
c'est toujours maintenant désormais ce
seront toutes les aventures de tintin
qui pourront être lues de 7 à 77 ans
e